merci à la Richard de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu du
Val-d'Oise bon du groupe rassemblement
de démocrate progressistes indépendant
c'est le groupe des sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle et vous êtes
vice-président du Sénat on va parler de
cette allocution d'Emmanuel Macron le
chef de l'État qui veut tourner la page
on va le voir dans quelques instants
mais d'abord cette allocution avec un
peu de recul est-ce que vous jugez
qu'elle a été utile il faut forcément
que le président indique ce qui va être
ensuite la mission du gouvernement des
parlementaires enfin du et des
partenaires sociaux de se donner un
certain nombre de projets de
d'objectif de finalité pour la période
qui vient alors il a dit les 100 jours
vraisemblablement une partie de ces
travaux vont se prolonger je crois qu'il
l'intention
dans les trois mois qui viennent
beaucoup de choses seront mises en route
et en effet après il y a une sujet
disons d'attente de résultats et il faut
qu'il y a un rythme c'est bien il faut
que les décisions qui qui sont prises
pensaient faire relativement vite est-ce
que le Président on a compris lundi soir
il cherche à tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites vous pensez
vraiment pouvoir réussir à tourner cette
page toutes les retraites toutes les
réformes de retraite qui ont eu lieu
depuis 20 ans
et peut-être même d'ailleurs c'est une
qui était assez problématique enfin qui
rendait la retraite moins intéressante
la première était prise par le
gouvernement d'Édouard Balladur en 94 je
suis bonne mémoire
toutes ces retraites toutes ces réformes
sont entrées dans les fêtes et sont
entrés aussi dans les réflexions et dans
le la sensibilité des Français donc vous
ne croyez
pas
personne n'a jamais fait cela dit j'ai
quand même vu on est collègues
socialiste dans la difficulté politique
signée un accord politique celui de la
nupes disons nous sommes pour la
retraite à 60 ans alors que
naturellement quand ils étaient quand
nous étions aux responsabilités ensemble
personne n'a envisagé de rabaisser la je
la retraite que c'est de la 62 ans et on
a rajouté la condition des 43 ans de
d'actifs 42 ans d'activité à l'époque
donc
je crois que même si c'est une réforme
qui entraîne en effet un effort
supplémentaire les Français vont entrer
dedans oui mais on le voit le président
et il y aura encore pendant
les mois peut-être les semaines qui
viennent des manifestations de
mécontentement mais qui je crois seront
concentrés de plus en plus sur un noyau
militant de personnes qui de toute façon
ont envie de contester le pouvoir actuel
en oubliant qu'elles ont été placées en
minorité par les électeurs et il y aura
donc des incidents des choses
déplaisantes par exemple au moment des
déplacements ministériels
donc il y a pas trop d'imprévus il veut
redouer avec les Français on le voit il
sera cet après-midi en Alsace demain
dans l'Hérault vous pensez que c'est
possible ou le lien est rompu entre lui
et les Français non je pense qu'il y a
un carnet français qui sont très
hostiles à la politique que nous menons
et
c'est vrai que ça sa sortie souvent
d'une crise passion ou de d'une d'une
aversion à l'égard de la personne du
chef de l'État et il y a un autre quart
un même un peu plus important qui dit
bon ça va à peu près c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce qu'on souhaitait c'est ce qu'on
croit souhaitable pour nous et pour le
pays et puis au milieu il y a un
éventail de d'opinion et de
position
des Français dans la vie publique qui
sont des accords sur certains points
mais que peuvent aussi reconnaître qu'il
y a des domaines dans lesquels on a
progressé on va continuer à progresser
comment vous faites pour les pour les
reconquérir ces Français qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire qu'est-ce que doit faire la
majorité présidentielle je crois qu'il y
a il y a deux sujets qui me paraissent
moi me premier le premier l'un des
sujets qui a été sur lequel les
projecteurs ont été mis par la réforme
des retraites c'est les conditions de
travail la sécurité au travail le la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
notamment pour les gens dans la deuxième
moitié de la vie professionnelle donc là
il y a des accords professionnels des
arrangements parce que on parle toujours
de l'épaisseur du Code du travail
60 ou 70% et c'est heureux de cette
épaisseur résulte d'accord entre les
organisations syndicales et employeurs
pour améliorer des garanties des
protections etc donc je pense qu'il y a
besoin une phase supplémentaire pour
accompagner mieux encadrer mieux
soutenir la deuxième partie de la vie
professionnelle et s'englobe de
retravailler sur le sujet de qui est
considéré comme en pénibilité pour le
calcul de la de la retraite anticipée ça
c'est le premier sujet le deuxième sujet
c'est le système de santé qui est à la
fois extraordinairement performant quand
on voit le claqualisé de soins dont nous
sommes capables et qui a des problèmes
d'effectif et d'organisation qui fait
que nous devons au moins garder les
emplois que nous avons et améliorer le
recrutement encore pour les personnes
les personnels médicaux et le distribué
correctement sur le territoire sur la
question du travail puisque
effectivement c'est un chantier
important on pensait que la loi travail
serait présentée avant les théières le
chef de l'État a dit qu'il essaie au
partenaires sociaux jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour négocier le nouveau pack
sur la vie au travail est-ce que ça veut
dire que la loi travail ne sera pas
présentée avant l'été je me pose aussi
la question et précisément ça correspond
au premier au premier moment de notre
échange moi ça faisait un moment que en
observant et enfin participant à tous
ces débat je me disais la loi travail en
fait nous avons que le quart des
articles a écrit le reste viendra les
partenaires sociaux bon donc si on veut
que ce soit conclusif si on veut que ça
apporte vraiment des changements qui
soient positifs pour les salariés et qui
permettent de garder tous les salariés
au travail c'est aussi ça c'est pas
multiplié les colliers de maladies les
inaptitudes etc
il vaut mieux qu'il prenne un peu le
temps donc ça à la présenter avant la
fin de l'année ça nous posera un
problème de management du calendrier
puisque on a du mal à passer un texte
enfin plusieurs textes importants
pendant la session on a le projet de loi
de finance et le financement de sécurité
sociale mais je pense qu'il faudra qu'on
le fasse je vous conseille d'attendre la
fin de Laurent Berger a dit qu'il
finirait par retourner à la table des
négociations vous comprenez sa position
vous comprenez qu'hier les syndicats ne
sont pas rendus à l'Elysées
en plus Laurent Berger c'est quand même
le l'homme qui a amené la CFDT après une
situation où les femmes moi j'ai cru
d'autres époques des situations dans
lesquelles en gros le poids de la CFDT
c'était la moitié du poil de la CGT
il a su prédécesseur aussi mais il est
celui sous la bannière duquel sous
l'autorité duquel la CFDT dans les
élections professionnelles quand les
salariés votent a obtenu la première
place de représentativité et mon
sentiment mais je peux être jugé un peu
partial et que
l'écart continuent à se creuser que la
CFDT gagne encore en niveau de confiance
donc
il avait
un mandat de son syndicat alors que le
débat avait lieu au sein du syndicat ils
ont est-ce qu'on accepte une nouvelle
réforme des retraites parce qu'on voit
bien que le système va pas s'équilibrer
c'est du genre parfaitement responsable
bon le résultat du Congrès donc une
représentativité de la base de CFDT
aboutit à dire non on négociera pas sur
ce point-là donc il a tenu sur cette
position il l'a fait loyalement et il a
et moi j'ai pas de critique apporter sur
la façon tu sais exprimer
beaucoup pris à la CFDT c'est une erreur
un sentiment de déception parce que
c'était naturellement le partenaire
qu'avec lequel on pensait pouvoir
dialoguer mais je crois qu'il faut qu'on
sache enfin je me mets à la place du
président il faut qu'on sache dominer ce
sujet de
désaccord et de mes enfants au moment
des retraites et il est clair que sur un
sujet en particulier comme les progrès
concrets
vécu à partir des conditions réelles de
travail sur lesquelles on va pouvoir
travailler la CFDT est un et à mon avis
l'interlocuteur qui travaille le plus
hier Gabriel Attal ont tous deux parlé
du plan de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale et socialiste sera présentée en
V et Bruno Le Maire a eu cette phrase
qui a fait réagir donc compatriotes on
aura le bol de la fraude ils en ont ras
le bol de voir des personnes qui peuvent
toucher des aides qu'il paye eux-mêmes
et les renvoyer au Maghreb ou ailleurs
alors qu'ils n'ont pas le droit le
modèle social n'est pas fait pour ça
vous approuvez ces propos
j'aurais eu mal à
dire d'abord le sujet de la lutte contre
la fraude est en préparation du
gouvernement est Gabriel nous en parle
pratiquement tous les 15 jours ça fait
trois ou quatre mois que le gouvernement
travaille là-dessus donc c'est pas une
ça sort pas du chapeau deuxièmement
toute fraude beaucoup de fraudes sont
internationales une partie importante
des pertes que nous faisons en recettes
de TVA par exemple viennent de
manipulation qui consiste à faire
rentrer et sortir parfois effectivement
d'ailleurs des marchandises imposables
de France et de la sortie bon donc en ce
qui concerne la fraude sociale
c'est-à-dire le les manœuvres ou les
fous les fous qui aboutissent à faire
bénéficier d'une personne de
de prestations auxquelles n'a pas droit
bien une partie se fait c'est vrai dans
des familles qui ont une branche de la
famille en France et une autre branche
de la famille dans un pays des
migrations donc franchement
de dire que ceux-ci est une offense à
quoi que ce soit c'est juste une réalité
que que chacun connaît et ça n'est pas
ce n'est pas scandaleux ne mentionner on
va parler Taïwan parce que vous êtes
président du groupe d'études français
one au Sénat les récents propos
d’emmanuel Macron sur la Chine et Hawaii
les Taïwan pardon ont provoqué la
conservation de nos alliés on en parle
avec notre journaliste parlementaire
Steve Jourdain
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le sénateur
et si Emmanuel Macron a suscité quelque
peu la polémique la semaine dernière
avec ses propos sur Taïwan vous nous
rappelez les fêtes oui trois jours de
visite d'État en Chine une interview une
quasi crise diplomatique on va voir les
propos qui ont suscité effectivement un
tollé auprès de nos alliés on est dans
l'avion entre Pékin et cantons Emmanuel
Macron déclare à nos confrères des échos
la chose suivante avant nous intérêt à
une accélération sur le sujet de Taïwan
non la pire des choses serait de penser
que nous Européens devrions être suivis
sur ce sujet et nous adapter au rythme
américain et une surréaction chinoise le
piège pour l'Europe serait qu'au moment
où elle parvient à une clarification de
sa position stratégique qu'elle soit
prise dans un dérèglement du monde et
des crises qui ne seraient pas les
nôtres fin de citation lever de bouclier
à Washington et dans les capitales
européennes on reproche notamment à
Emmanuel Macron de ne pas choisir entre
la démocratie américaine et le
totalitarisme chinois qui ambitionne de
mettre la main sur Taïwan quelques
heures plus tard le chef de l'État a
précisé sa pensée écoutez-le
France
soutient la politique d'une seule Chine
et la recherche d'un règlement pacifique
de la situation c'est d'ailleurs la
position des Européens
et c'est une position qui de tout temps
a été compatible avec le rôle d'Allier
mais c'est justement là que j'insiste
sur l'importance de l'autonomie
stratégique être alignée ne signifie pas
être vassal c'est pas parce qu'on est
allié qu'on fait des choses ensemble
qu'on décide de faire qu'on a plus le
droit de penser tout seul et si que peut
la France dans ce conflit alors que
rappelons-le nous n'avons pas de
relation diplomatique avec Taïwan oui
c'est vrai officiellement Paris
n'entretien pas de relation avec lui
mais officieusement des échanges
existent bel et bien il y en a même
beaucoup notamment en matière économique
en matière scientifique un chiffre pour
vous montrer l'importance de Taïwan dans
l'économie mondiale l'île produit près
de 60% des semis conducteurs de la
planète il s'agit de ces puces
électroniques indispensables pour les
voitures les avions les smartphones et
qui dit en jeu économiques dit aussi
intérêt politique pour l'Occident des
parlementaires seront donc régulièrement
sur l'île on va voir des images de
sénateurs en visite à Taïwan c'était
début septembre 5 élus ont été
accueillis on voit par les autorités
locales en ce qui vous concerne à la
Richard vous aviez fait le déplacement
c'était en 2021 vous êtes on rappelle le
président du groupe changer d'études
Sénat Taïwan après les propos d'Emmanuel
Macron vous dites quoi au taiwanais
pardon pour cette bourde
je dirais simplement que le président a
trop résumé sa pensée et à trop
concentré la l'expression de ce qu'il
voulait dire son sujet était la relation
Europe États-Unis dans la discussion
avec la Chine et ce qui voulait montrer
c'est que il y avait tellement d'intérêt
en jeu que ce soit de sécurité ou
économique que les européens devaient
manœuvrer collectivement et ne pas
forcément suivre les initiatives des
États-Unis parce que faut pas qu'on ait
la mémoire trop courte les initiatives
de des États-Unis ça peut aussi être des
initiatives à la Trump avec des effets
problématique
que c'était une gaffe ou une erreur ce
qui boit m'a paru ennuyeux c'est qu'il
emploie l'expression des crises qui ne
sont pas les
alors qu'il venait de parler des
relations avec la Chine donc de dire que
la situation et la tension sur la Chine
sur Taïwan n'est pas notre problème ça
c'est parce qu'il pensait et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu besoin d'une
rectification
et par ailleurs il y a une tension entre
européen ça c'est vrai entre ceux qui
pensent et nous sommes parmi évidemment
les premiers les premiers historiquement
à dire l'Europe doit assumer sa propre
protection même si elle a une alliance
avec les États-Unis qui est une alliance
régionale qui pense sur la sécurité de
l'Europe et de
l'Amérique du Nord ça n'est pas une
alliance qui porte sur la situation dans
le monde entier bon même s'il y a une
coopération donc nous pensons que dans
cette alliance l'Europe doit assumer
plus c'est plus forte responsabilité ce
qui implique d'ailleurs de mieux s'armer
on voit le on voit le déficit à l'heure
actuelle alors que une partie de nos
amis européens je pense notamment à la
ça c'est le cas le plus flagrant disent
nous n'avons confiance que dans la
protection des États-Unis donc l'idée
d'une défense européenne autonome nous
paraît être mal placé en creux dans les
propos d'Emmanuel Macron il rejette un
peu la tension dans les trois Taïwan sur
les États-Unis est-ce que c'est ce que
vous avez aussi entendu est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec avec cette analyse
voilà vous avez bien fait de remontrer
la phrase écrite il n'a pas dit ça
exactement mais comme vous parlez de
rythme américain et de surréaction
chinoise
et que vous êtes en vous êtes en Chine
vous laissez vous faites comprendre que
ce qui se passe à Taïwan viendrait d'une
action américaine sur laquelle les
Chinois réagiraient alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu la visite de Madame Pelosi
qui était pas forcément
tout à fait judicieux et qui n'était pas
demandé par les Taïwanais d'ailleurs
mais
la propension de la Chine va pouvoir
chinois actuel à vouloir exercer une une
pression armée sur Taïwan la reconquête
par la violence c'est pas une idée c'est
pas une idée américaine et d'ailleurs
les États-Unis continuent à dire que il
n'ont pas de traité d'alliance avec
Taiwan et qui considère pas que l'action
américaine serait automatique dans une
telle situation vous allez je crois
faire le déplacement à Taïwan dans
quelques jours quel est l'objectif de se
déplacement c'est de se concerter avec
les d'abord nous parle nos partenaires
parlementaires et parler des évolutions
de législation et des progrès qui se
font chez eux mais c'est aussi un effet
dialoguer avec le gouvernement sur leur
situation de sécurité et puis sur les
échanges économiques du fait que Taïwan
ils le font parfois remarquer
malicieusement pourrait être au G20
puisque c'est la 20e économie mondiale
donc nous avons beaucoup de relations
notamment sur le sur le champ évidemment
de process et d'électronique et donc
vous allez dans quelques jours avec une
partie des sénateurs
de la faute sociale tout à l'heure ce
sera à suivre dans le club un mot sur la
loi de programmation militaire à la
Richard vous êtes ancien ministre de la
Défense le gouvernement souhaite adopter
cette loi 2024-2030 d'ici l'été 413
milliards d'euros c'est le budget mais
le texte a connu un premier revers à
l'Assemblée nationale suspendue de l'or
du jour parce que les républicains
suivis par les autres oppositions ont
mis en cause l'étude d'impact qui porte
sur les dispositions financières le
Conseil constitutionnel doit se
prononcer vous comprenez la démarche des
républicains je comprends comme une
manœuvre d'opposition ça fait partie ils
ont le droit de soulever ce problème et
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
il y a pas une majorité qui suit
habituellement le gouvernement au sein
de la Conférence et présidents la règle
qui a été fixée par une réforme
constitutionnelle qui est juste à mon
avis en 2008 c'est que une loi
un projet de loi apporté par le
gouvernement doit comporter toute une
série de documentations et de
justificatifs qui démontre que la
solution le faire une nouvelle loi se
justifie et va produire on en attend des
résultats qu'on est capable de d'évaluer
de chiffrer bon et donc sur le fond
c'est justifié ou c'est une démarche
politique il y a de vrais la culture
financière constitutionnel mais il y a
quand même une masse d'informations et
de donner qui permet de voir ce que va
être l'impact de cette loi de
programmation militaire sur 6 ans avec
une série de transformation
industrielles comme c'est l'objet des
lois de programmation depuis le général
de Gaulle donc
il me semble qu'il y a largement de quoi
informer le Parlement sur ce que vont
entraîner les mesures de la loi de
programmation mais en droit la espérance
des présidents peut dire STOP nous
demandons à ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel atteste vérifie que la
l'étude d'impact est suffisante et et le
gouvernement peut aussi compléter
l'étude d'impact apporter des données
supplémentaires pour faciliter le
dialogue donc moi je ne perds pas espoir
après tout on peut siéger jusqu'au 20 ou
25 juillet je ne perds
pas le fait que la loi sera adoptée
c'est vraiment viser un peu à côté de la
cible parce que tout le monde voit que
la loi de programmation militaire
apporte un soutien très important à nos
armées permet d'accélérer un certain
nombre de programmes et de d'aboutir à
la dotation en armement aux dernières
étapes de technique de nos armées donc
sur le fond je suis à peu près sûr que
tout le monde va voter pour à la fin et
un mot donc pas de conséquence pour vous
sur le calendrier sur les fabricants
d'équipements là non plus pour vous ça
va pas de conséquences
pour eux elle est faite en tout cas pour
leur dire voilà ce qui va se passer non
non le retard il va se compter en
semaine donc pas d'impact on va aller
voir l'actualité du côté de chez vous on
va à servir retrouver romain Chiron
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
chef d'édition du Parisien Val-d'Oise et
Romain on revient avec vous sur
l'aménagement du Triangle de Gonesse
quels sont les enjeux d'abord
les enjeux ils durent depuis maintenant
plusieurs années
l'enjeu c'était un énorme projet
d'urbanisation sur ces terres agricoles
avec le projet europacity un méga
complexe de loisirs commerce et
restaurants soutenu par la majorité des
élus locaux mais
contester par les associations de
défense de l'environnement
ce projet a finalement été abandonné en
2019 par Emmanuel Macron qui jugé ce
modèle dépassé
ça a pas forcément mis fin à tous les
projets d'aménagement il y en a toujours
qui sont en cours et notamment une garde
du Grand Paris Express qui doit arriver
à l'horizon 2028 une gare au milieu des
champs selon ses détracteurs moi je
voulais interroger monsieur Richard sur
le rôle de les locaux de l'élu local
pardon sur ce genre de projet vous avez
été maire de Saint-Ouen-l'Aumône pendant
longtemps député du Val d'Oise également
je voulais savoir en tant qu'il lui
local est-ce que les enjeux économiques
avec les retombées d'emploi qu'il y a
aussi derrière ce que ça prend le bas ou
pas sur les enjeux
environnementaux écoutez nous avons
transformé toutes les villes de France
depuis deux siècles en réalité si vous
prenez la carte de l'Île-de-France au
début du 19e siècle et la carte
aujourd'hui il est clair que nous avons
transformé cet espace et que
l'agriculture et la nature ayant perdu
de la disponibilité et que les hommes et
leurs activités et leurs conditions de
vie on s'occupait une place plus grande
et puis la mobilité devront plus
importante on a créé toutes les tout le
réseau de transport public donc je sais
bien que nous devons aller vers un
ralentissement puis un arrêt de la
consommation d'espace encore faut-il
qu'on sache bien mesurer quand on
consomme de l'espace en perdant de la
biodiversité car il y a aussi de la
biodiversité dans les espaces urbains et
c'est notre job en tant qu’elle locaux
de la préserver et de la et de la
renforcer et donc pour aller sur le
sujet du triangle
je rappelle que c'est une vague une zone
d'aménagement prévue par l'État depuis
plus de 15 ans et qui a un objectif
d'emploi pour l'essentiel puisque nous
sommes à la croisée des voies de
transport
et les voies routières qui viennent de
l'autoroute de vin de l'aéroport parlant
Charles de Gaulle et du Nord et donc ces
terrains-là on veut vocation à fournir
de l'activité supplémentaire et vous
n'ignorez pas que ce même secteur est
marqué par 5 ou 6 grandes communes qui
sont billiers-le-bel Sarcelles Garges
Gonesse Goussainville qui sont des cités
populaires avec lesquels dans lesquels
il y a encore des déficits d'emploi donc
moi je n'ai pas de doute que une partie
en tout cas du Triangle de Gonesse doit
être comme c'est prévu comme c'est dans
les textes comme c'est dans la
régularité
urbanisée et urbanisée pour fournir de
l'activité économique et de l'emploi
ma question c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui je pense de de
concilier cette cette problématique de
préservation des terres agricoles et
effectivement avec cette nécessité de
développement économique dans un
département en plus qui est le plus
jeune d'Île-de-France qui est très
dynamique et oui il y a des aménagements
qui sont nécessaires à faire avec un
conseiller qui est peu important aussi
oui mais
plus d'emplois hors de Paris veut le
dire aussi moins de concentration moins
de tension urbaine c'est-à-dire que
quand vous regardez le parcours depuis
20 ou 25 ans la proportion des emplois
de France qui sont hors de Paris et qui
se développent dans des sites mieux
adaptés
avec un peu d'espace et de possibilités
d'évolution dans le temps c'est un peu
plus la création de la défense il y a
plus de 60 ans c'est un process qui
continue à se développer et qui est ça à
mon avis pour une agglomération la
présidente de la région parle maintenant
d'une région des 20 minutes c'est à dire
que on est son emploi sa formation son
lycée etc
relativement proximité de chez soi sans
avoir tout faire en passant par Paris il
me semble que l'aménagement du triangle
a un endroit qui est déjà desservi et on
n'est pas on n'est pas à 100 ou 150
hectares d'agriculture de de plaine près
vraiment que c'est un projet qu'il faut
soutenir puisqu'on parle de votre
département la Richard vous faites
partie des départements renouvelables
pour les sénatoriales de septembre vous
serez candidat à votre réflexion
merci merci
je commencerai je commencerai à
présenter ma campagne et ma liste dans
quelques semaines oui et on suivra tout
ça merci à la Richard merci d'être venu
nous voir merci Romain Chiron d'avoir
été avec nous la une du Parisien c'est
Carrefour lèvent le tabou sur les congés
menstruels c'est la une du Parisien ce
matin merci beaucoup romain d'avoir été
avec nous merci à la Richard d'être venu
nous voir pendant cette première
demi-heure et donc c'était un plaisir
merci merci beaucoup dans 20 minutes
dans le top des territoires on parlera
d'Emmanuel Macron peut-il tourner la
page de la réforme des retraites comme
il le souhaite il multiplier les
déplacements on va voir tout ça dans le
club et on en parle tout de suite avec
notre invité Sébastien Chenu